for the best performance by an actress  in a supporting role the nominees are  Goldie Hawn in cactus flower  Diane cannon in Bob and Carol and Ted  and Alice Catherine burns in last summer  Sylvia miles in Midnight Cowboy and  Susannah York in they shoot horses don't  they  the winner is Goldie Hawn  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  as you see Raquel Welch will accept the  goalie Han who cannot be here thank you  but I'm it's a pleasure to accept this  award for her she couldn't be here  because she's in London filming but I  know she would want to thank all her  co-stars Walter Matthau and Ingrid  Bergman for director Gene sacks and Mike  Frank a [ __ ] and I think it's wonderful  for her thank you  [Applause]